OK, let's take a break from the world of lies
coming to us from the White House about the
virus.
Let's look at science.
All right.
If you've been watching our show, you would
already know about a bunch of possible treatments,
not game changers, the way Trump is saying.
We're talking about possible corona virus
treatments.
The question has mostly been, are these safe
enough to use in proper clinical trials?
And when might that start?
The World Health Organization is starting
an unprecedented quadruple clinical trial
where doctors around the world can participate.
This is called solidarity.
I don't know if that is an acronym for something.
It may be.
Maybe, maybe not.
This is basically taking what would often
be a very long process and compressing it
into simultanous trials.
They are not blinded trials.
We'll talk about that in a second.
And four different treatments are going to
be tried because we have so many patients.
You can try four different things at once
compared to placebo and the standard treatment.
In this case, they may not be using placebo.
That may be unethical given the circumstances.
Thousands of patients across multiple countries
are going to be included.
Now, this is being done both to consider these
drugs as treatments for people who are already
sick, but also with the possibility that maybe
some of these could become prophylactics in
advance of a vaccine to protect people from
the virus.
We don't know.
That's what's being tested.
All right.
The four drugs being tested would be familiar
to anyone who's been watching our show since
I told you about these weeks ago.
We've got the anti-viral REM desert here.
That's from Gilli.
AD Farma developed for Ebola.
Didn't work well for Ebola going to be tested
in this large W.H.O. clinical trial.
Number two already spoke about it, chloroquine
or hydroxy chloroquine, another form of the
same drug around since 1934, used to treat
malaria.
Side effects can include muscle problems,
loss of appetite, diarrhea and skin rash.
Serious side effects can include vision issues,
muscle damage, seizures, low blood cell levels,
which itself can lead to subsequent problems.
Small test showed it worked on a small sample
of coronavirus patients.
It was not blinded and it was not randomized.
Now there will be more testing done in combination
with a zero Meissen.
Number three, a combination of two HIV drugs,
low pin of there and Raton of air.
That's the third trial that's being done.
And then lastly, the fourth test will be those
two HIV drugs.
Le Pen.
Le Pen here and return of air.
With the addition of interfer on beta, doctors
will be able to put their patients information
into a W.H.O. computer system, see who's eligible
for which test account for underlying conditions,
which may make someone not a good candidate
for one test, but may be an OK candidate for
another.
This is a man massive major undertaking.
This is the large trial that we've been waiting
for, which starts this week.
Now, of course, looking at already approved
drugs, drugs approved for other things is
going to be the fastest path, much faster
than developing new drugs for sure.
But then in addition, they're also looking
at adding trials of drugs that have not yet
been approved, but that have worked well in
animal trials on other types of respiratory
viruses.
Meurs, SaaS, et cetera.
So as I mentioned, again, these are not double
blind tests.
Double-blind would be neither the doctor nor
the patient knows who's getting which treatment.
The idea is you prevent a placebo.
You prevent the doctor from consciously or
subconsciously giving the trial treatment
to patients that may be predisposed to do
better.
Any way that would skew the data.
But still, this is the way it's being done.
A number of medical ethicists, including our
friend from NYU, Arthur Caplan, say given
the circumstances, this this is a good test.
So, as always, none of these things will give
us answers as soon as we would like.
The sooner you start, the sooner you get data,
the sooner you can start to figure out whether
one of these may may be a good path forward.
Sometimes when you do this, you will very
quickly see one of these four treatments is
significantly better than the standard treatment
and significantly better than the other treatments
that are being tested.
When the results are overwhelming in these
emergency situations, you will stop sometimes
see the case made that you need to drastically
expand giving patients the treatment that
appears to be working.
We just don't know yet.
Then you have to start dealing with supply
and distribution issues, all sorts of other
things.
Those would be figured out.
So that's the big trial going on.
Unprecedented quadruple clinical trial.
We'll see what comes from it.
Let's have realistic expectations.
Make sure.
For more on these trials, follow The David
Pakman Show on Instagram at David Pakman.
So while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman to see what I've been up to
during the day during the self-quarantined